Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel.
And my name is Paul many European languages share a lot of features
that seem to be the norm or the default to speakers of those languages,
but are actually quite unusual amongst the thousands of languages of the world.
And many of those features can't be traced back to a common ancestor language or
prodo language. Rather it's believed that there is a European Shiprock.
Boone's an area in which various languages have influenced each other through
geographic proximity and contact.
The Shiprock Puente is sometimes referred to as the European linguistic area.
And the set of shared linguistic features is referred to as standard average
European.
Most of the languages of the standard average European struck Puente are
Indo-European languages,
but since [inaudible] is a geographic area of contact and influence,
there are some non Indo-European languages that are also marginal members of it
as well, including Finnish and Hungarian.
Most features of standard average European are not from prodo Indo-European,
but are later innovations,
which then spread to other European languages features that are clearly part of
standard. Average,
European are found in a core of European languages are not found in the Armenian
Iranian or Indic branches of Indo-European and are not found in the majority of
the world's languages,
Sprocket boons affect different languages to different degrees.
So there are some core languages that exhibit most of the features of standard
average European, and there are others that exhibit fewer,
this map shows nine characteristic features of standard average European,
and the number of features exhibited by different languages at the core live
French and German, which exhibit all nine features Dutch Spanish,
Portuguese Sardinian, Italian and Albanian each exhibit eight,
English Romanian and Greek exhibit seven, the North Germanic languages,
as well as check exhibit six, Latvian Lithuanian,
Russian Ukrainian, Polish, Hungarian, Bulgarian, Slovenian, Serbian,
and Croatian,
all exhibit five features languages with fewer than five features are not really
considered part of standard average European.
Even though there may be some peripheral influence.
Now let's take a look at those nine features. Number one,
having both definite and indefinite articles like the, and ah,
in English only about one third of the world's languages have articles and the
number of languages with both definite and indefinite articles is much smaller.
So it's remarkable that in Europe,
so many languages have both and that's evidence of the standard average European
[inaudible]
, which languages have. These features, all the romance languages, all Germanic languages, except for Icelandic, which is the most geographically peripheral Germanic language, some bulk in languages, including modern Greek and
maybe
Albanian and Bulgarian, which don't have it Baltic and Slavic languages possibly aside from Bulgarian here, we can see the German definite indefinite articles in all of their inflected
forums
. Here. We can see the French definite and indefinite articles. And here we see the Hungarian definite and indefinite articles. Number two, relative clauses with relative pronouns. These are relative clauses that come after the
note
with a relative pronoun that changes depending on the function of the head of the sentence, for instance, in English, the man who drives the car versus the
man whose car I drove in German in German, the relative pronoun
comes from a demonstrative pronoun, but in most cases, the relative pronoun comes from an interrogative pronoun. In other words, a question word like.
[Inaudible] and in modern Greek.
As you can see from the map, this feature is widespread.
Even outside of the core standard average European languages. Number three,
the have perfect. Like I have finished the report in English.
This is a paraphrase stick,
perfect tense using the verb have plus a past participle,
such a construction exists in all romance languages,
all Germanic languages and some bulk in languages,
including modern Greek Albanian and Macedonian. In some of these languages,
it has a simple past meaning. And in other languages,
it has a present perfect meaning. Here's an example in German
and in French.
And in modern Greek [inaudible].
Number four, a passive formed within and transitive linking verb.
Plus a past participle. For example, in English, the car was stolen.
This kind of passive is used in all romance, Germanic and Slavic languages,
other languages of the Balkans, as well as to Celtic languages,
Irish and Breton among others in German
and in French.
[Inaudible] in Polish [inaudible] and in Britain
[inaudible].
This type of passive is rare outside of standard average European,
but it should be noted that it does appear in Iranian and Indic languages.
So maybe it's an Indo-European feature rather than just a standard average
European Shiprock wound feature. Number five dates of external possessors.
These occur when the possessor and the thing that's possessed appear in separate
noun phrases with the possessor being in the date of case or an indirect object.
For example, in German de-motivation
meaning the mother is washing the child's hair,
but word for word it's the mother washes the child date of case,
the hair accusative case, and then example in Spanish,
meaning I haven't seen his face,
but word for word it's no him indirect object have seen the face
number six negative pronouns with no verbal negation. For example, in English,
nobody came notice that the verb is not negated.
This type of negation occurs in all Germanic languages, French oxytocin,
Ibero romance,
and to tell a romance languages as well as Albanian one romance language that
doesn't appear in his Romanian. It's also absent from Slavic languages,
urologic languages and others in German. And in.
French, if we.
Ignore the main negation word, pot is not here to negate the verb.
And these days people often skip the nut anyway, in Spanish and Italian,
this type of negation is used,
but if the negative pronoun is an object after the verb,
as opposed to the subject, then the verb is negated. For example, in Spanish
seven comparisons of equality,
based on an adverbial relative clause in English,
we have comparisons like as tall as me in German, this would be.
[Inaudible] V E V.
Being a relative adverb. In other words,
it's used to introduce a relative clause like in this sentence,
meaning I like how you think in English as is not used to introduce
relative clauses like that, but it derives from L swab or also,
which was used as a relative pronoun in the past. And in modern Greek.
Does subsea LA or psycho.
This feature appears in the romance languages, West Germanic languages,
Slavic languages, Hungarian, Albanian, and modern Greek.
It's not found in North dramatic languages finish the Celtic languages.
And so on number eight,
non-pro drop perhaps a more precise term for this is strict subject
agreement in most languages.
Verbs usually have ethics as that indicate the subject and very commonly the
explicit subject pronouns can be dropped for example, in Arabic [inaudible]
, which means I love you when spoken to a female, we know from the prefix, ah
, that this is first person singular. So the subject Ana meaning I
is often left out, but in certain European languages, including the core standard average European languages
of
French and German, as well as Dutch, English, Welsh and Icelandic, the subject pronouns
cannot
be dropped. Even though there are affixes that agree with the subject. For example, in German, the subject pronoun here is necessary and can't be dropped.
This is one feature that only applies to a limited number of standard average
European languages in Spanish. For example, [inaudible] means I love you.
Spanish is pro drop. The subject pronoun here can be left out.
But as a side note in Spain,
it would be more common to express love by saying guilty or ghetto,
meaning I want you,
but in friendships French's non-pro drop.
So the subject pronoun is required even though syntactically,
it completely lines up with the Spanish sentence.
If the pronoun is included in the Spanish
number nine intensifier reflexive distinction in English,
we use the word self and its derivatives myself himself.
And so on as an intensifier, for example,
the president himself gave a speech at our school in the sentence.
The word himself is an intensifier.
It emphasizes that it's the president and not someone else who gave a speech at
the school, but in English and in many languages,
such intensifiers are also used as reflexive pronouns as well. For example,
he loves himself,
but a typical feature of standard average European languages is that different
words are used for the intensifier and for the reflexive in German,
meaning the president himself and
meaning he loves himself and in Polish.
I'm president. And [inaudible].
Again, we have the intensifier and the reflexive pronoun,
which are different in French.
I don't remember. And [inaudible].
This is the direct translation of, he loves himself in French,
but this isn't really a natural sentence for that meaning.
So another example with a reflexive pronoun.
Is meaning.
He sees himself in the mirror.
Obviously this differentiation does not occur in English or in Dutch either,
but it occurs in many standard average European languages,
including those which tend to have fewer Sprocket bone features like the North
dramatic languages, Latvian and Lithuanian, and the Slavic languages,
even Basque Basque is a language isolate and not considered a standard average
European language because it doesn't share enough of the [inaudible] features,
but it does share a couple of them.
This is a good example of how [inaudible] can have varying degrees of impact on
different languages, depending on geography and contact.
Those nine features are considered highly likely to be part of a European
Shiprock Puente.
There are numerous other features which may be part of the Sprott Puente as
well, but are less certain one such feature is SVO word order.
S V O for example, in English, I love languages.
S V O and in German
S V O S VO is not limited to Europe,
but within Europe it seems to correspond well with the other core standard
average European features.
There's also an absence of certain features that are common in other regions of
the world. One example is the absence of reduplicate.
Reduplicate is the repetition of a word or part of a word,
usually to change something about its meaning or function. For example,
in Indonesia, there's the word honor, which means child.
And that is the plural form. Meaning children,
this type of reduplicate is almost totally absent from standard average European
languages. How did the Sprocket Boont arise?
It's hard to know exactly what historical events or conditions contributed to
the spread of standard average European features. But according to Martin,
[inaudible], who's
the source of most of the information in this video, the most likely hypothesis is that it happened during the migration period between roughly 300 and 700 CE during the transition from late antiquity to the early middle ages.
During this time, the Western Roman empire declined then collapsed,
which triggered widespread invasions into and within Europe,
particularly into the territory of the empire,
the resulting migrations must've brought many languages into contact with each
other. Of course, this may be responsible for some of the Spock wound features.
While other features may have spread as a result of different historical events.
One of the most fascinating things about languages as that,
they are a result of everything that has happened to their speakers and their
ancestors. Up until this point.
The question of the day is the rush Brock Puente in your region,
or is there another Spock, boom,
you've heard about what kind of shared features are there,
let us know in the comments down below, if you enjoyed this video,
then be sure to check out Lang focus on the various social media platforms like
Facebook, YouTube, Twitter, and Instagram. And as always,
I want to say thank you to my Patrion supporters,
especially these wonderful Patrion supporters right here on the screen,
my top tier of Patrion supporters, many extra special,
thanks to them and to everyone. Thank you for watching and have a nice day.